despojados de su nacionalidad esa fue
una de las penas adoptadas para 94
positores por decisión de las
autoridades nicaragüenses este miércoles
también se les prohibió ejercer cargos
públicos y puestos de elección popular
al mismo tiempo se les decomisaron sus
bienese la pérdida de la nacionalidad
nicaragüense de todo los acusados
ténganse a lo acusados como traidores a
la patria la determinación incluye los
reconocidos escritores Sergio Ramírez
que en el pasado ejerció como
vicepresidente Danilo Ortega y a
yocondavelli una voz crítica del
gobierno desde el exilio también a Luis
Carrión ex comandante de la Revolución
sandinista que llevó al derrocamiento
del régimen de Anastasio somoza en 1979
en la amplia lista resaltan los nombres
del periodista y director de él
confidencial Carlos Fernando Chamorro
del obispo auxiliar de Managua Silvio
báez y del ex embajador de Nicaragua
ante Arturo macfield un gran honor estar
en esta lista soy nicaragüense gracias a
Dios Nicaragua los condenados van a ser
ellos el tribunal de apelaciones de
Managua los acusó de Conspiración y de
propagación de noticias falsas la
mayoría de los sentenciados este
miércoles tienen un punto en común jugar
un papeles claves dentro del frente
sandinista de liberación nacional
pasaron de serafines al partido de
gobierno a convertirse en unos de sus
grandes detractores la decisión se
enmarca en una ley que regula la pérdida
de la nacionalidad nicaragüense aprobada
el jueves 9 de febrero una determinación
que ha derivado en una ola de destierros
estos 94 opositores se suman a los 222
presos que el gobierno de Ortega envió
en un avión a Estados Unidos la semana
pasada